I had to read I think for articles today
to begin to understand the strange word
you live everyday maneuver who's
maneuvering in Washington and would you
please explain the maneuvering of the
maneuver in odd Alliance Tom it with
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
House Speaker John Boehner and the White
House a group of people that usually
don't talk very much certainly don't get
along they were the ones who really made
this happen and what we're going to see
tonight you mentioned they will vote to
give the president fast-track authority
on these trade agreements this is
something that the US Trade
Representative Michael Froman has said
is absolutely necessary to move forward
on the trans-pacific partnership that's
that 12-nation deal the biggest trade
deal in history possibly income Singh up
to forty percent of the global economy
this is a key legacy moment for the
Obama administration and those maneuvers
you mentioned Tom look a week ago this
was dead two weeks ago nobody thought
this had a chance to move through its
been those procedural maneuvers that
have cleared a path way to get at least
in the near term this victory and
Brendan it's like Senator Byrd of
another time and place the acclaimed
West Virginia senator it is these deals
are hard to do and they're a heavy lift
and they happen once every decade I'm
gonna focus on three words you just said
Phil key legacy I remember what the
third one was two of them key legacy
it's good I'm historic legacy how
important is the is is is the
unwillingness to actually give the
president a loss how important is that
in the calculations the Democrats right
now you know I think look they made a
statement right they felt like they
hadn't been paid enough attention to
over the last six years and they wanted
to let the White House know that look we
don't need you anymore for elections you
need to pay better attention us i think
the White House looked at this
calculated that it was more valuable for
them to go ahead and push the Democrats
aside and work with Republicans here I
don't think this is the be-all end-all
of the relationship but i think
democrats made an important important
statement guys that ain't nancy pelosi
made very clear she matters her
leadership still matters in the white
house no matter what they do we'll
always have to pay attention to her Phil
ten seconds ten seconds when does the
president sign this bill by the end of
this week top okay Phil Mattingly thank
you so much in Washington